good morning Millennials how are my
favorite Millennials today the
Millennials are amazing today because
they are so riding me auntie hi as are
we oh my gosh okay so yesterday as you
know clearly we made it out of live so
thank you for all of your thoughts and
prayers [ __ ] Theo sorry I know you
said don't get distracted by him but he
was being so good
Tiggy you want to treat just let him
roam okay let him explore the great
outdoors okay the other fake oh my god
he's being crazy okay okay well
yesterday we didn't know if you're gonna
make it out alive and honestly I was
really still out I was expecting NT to
be using like a mechanism to mask his
voice or something and he wasn't he had
like a hot straight man like sexy voice
and I was like super into it me too
it was everything I needed to see in
more I would still never said I'm still
nervous and then I started reading like
other minds cuz there were a few times
where she's like alluded to something
and then like didn't finish saying it
like he said something about jzj yeah
and I was like what's about jay-z except
for the fact that they're fake mm-hmm
there's so much about jay-z I really
well someone put in the toasters like I
don't even want to mention it all
because Lee's do know I can fine
but I just want to say he was super nice
like just as like a human being and um
he told me that if I come to LA he would
get drink with me and he's toasty as
hell like yeah sure toaster he did
research understood the nuances between
like lion eye and like music and he knew
that she wants us to go visit her and he
said that we should visit her and I'm if
auntie says we should then we should or
else we'll have blind certain about us
totally and now also I feel like if I
ever really do anything salacious like
he wouldn't write it up if he got like a
tip about me because he's my friend he
said he doesn't do oh and me a jack you
think we figured out the couple yeah
it was really just me but we're not
gonna say who is just in case it's
actually them but people had really good
guesses too
why not why can we go because what if we
blow it up and then we never get lines
from what he said was that probably one
of his biggest I'm totally right I know
I am one of his biggest tipsters is a
couple who go to they get into a tree of
their yeah both of their careers between
either they're there as someone's wife
or husband or they're there for
themselves they get to go to every event
and it's always so interesting how he
literally has the best scoop from like
Music Awards like the Grammys the B be
amazed but also like the Oscars and it's
like who is a couple that gets to go to
both things and it's cool enough to be
like in the know Nicole Kidman and Tom I
mean and Keith Urban and then I thought
he said on the podcast he is a real
distaste for Tom Cruise and Scientology
in general which would make sense if
he's taking a coke him inside because
Nicole Kidman has been giving him scoop
for years and I never really see blinds
about Keith Urban and Nicole Kidman so
I've seen some actually now that I think
about it especially about Keith Urban
but what are they sorry I think like big
drinking and stuff no other people guest
Chrissy and John which is a good guest
because they also are at everything yeah
but there are blinds about them too but
then people were saying Dan used to be
on Gossip Girl
even though he was a course it would be
too obvious right so that makes sense
and then also people guest Mario Lopez
and his wife I'm not just what if I
don't know but maybe she's in the biz
and then that would make sense cuz he
hosts all these like red carpets but he
never like gets invited inside he's more
of an outsider so you think I don't know
it's just it's very interesting thing
about but it also might be two people
who are just like in the biz but like a
producer thing the scenes I'm just like
fully embracing my legs these days
because it's just too damn hot to do
otherwise
yeah it's liberating not in here maybe
when we go outside but I've never had to
hide for very long so except for
yesterday when I took a pedicab home
because I couldn't get a cab and they
literally were my phone was dead so I
couldn't get an uber and the pedicab
pulled up and I was like if you take
credit card and he did so I got in he
like literally didn't actually they get
around sofa I got home so quickly it was
so nice I was living the life Riley with
the breeze nicely super nice one time I
took a $90 pedicab because it was Gay
Pride and it was like inflation this guy
knew he was businessman he knew how much
he could charge and I would still pay
for it and then I took it was some girl
and we split it and we became lifelong
friends that's wonderful yes it's like
pedicabs don't get enough ly put their
lives in danger
they really do but they don't like other
people's last in danger like all the
time a few times I felt like my life was
in danger like it felt like the the seat
was gonna unhinge me a bike and I've
seen me in the middle of the road okay
for those who don't know what a pedicab
is it's like that trolley it took a
rickshaw that's like
hold buy a bike yeah like you're sitting
on a very guilty my skinny man pulling
my big fat Jewish ass like he's gonna
die no but like it's such a great
workout for them and they're making
money I think it's actually like kind of
a dream job if you're into like that
sort of thing
yeah really want to get on the bike I'm
not gonna really think I thought about
it and like a soul cycle bike or a real
bike a real bike but I'm too scared to
bike in the city even though there are
bike lanes no one respects the bike lane
he's climbing I should know that I'd oh
I certainly know all right well as
always Jackie my dear sister oh I have a
story hold on before we jump into the
best five so to have like huge bags are
my eyes okay
yes right I worked on something so long
and so hard on a computer that literally
I when I looked up from it my eyes were
like I had huge red patches I was okay
so I read his official announcement I'm
not throwing a party at the bachelor
mansion or anything but I relaunched my
Claudia calm girl job calm because I
feel like there should be a place for
everyone to go like to see where all the
show tickets are that was literally just
the whole point and I just and I'm not
paying someone five thousand dollars to
make me a website one like [ __ ] I know
how to do it for free
oh my god I thought I knew I did you it
for free for it was easy at first then I
needed to add each individual show at
individual venues at different times oh
my god my eyes were bleeding and like
then after I did it all like the website
when you went to girls no joke I'm like
sorry this website doesn't exist so I
was like excuse me so it's officially up
go check it out Claudia comms also girls
with job comments the same exact thing
and honestly there's nothing on it
except where all my shows are and how to
buy tickets so pretty it's good that is
great and I launched Denver show today
so if you're in the toasters group when
are you going to Denver 7:21 let me just
check my website I'll tell you know it's
July 21st
oriental theater ten o'clock and did you
get your planner yet um it's supposed to
be arriving today and honestly I've
never needed it more I'm so overwhelmed
this is music to my ears because now
that everyone's booking these shows from
either act is estate work freedom like I
don't know like I know I have a couple
weddings this summer and like I cannot
miss something important I'm like I just
thought of another wedding [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay like I'm just I'm Chuck and then
you could just visualize yeah and Google
Calendar sucks no Google Calendar is
great if you work at a company and you
need to
Julian meetings and then like people can
find can't find a meeting place yeah I
think like black off your calendar it's
great for like from 9:00 to 5:00 but
it's great for Olivia yeah but not like
for dinner plans I couldn't agree more
weddings and I don't want to
notification about my dinner like a
total I just yeah it's just I'm also I
have like the morning toast in my Google
Calendar everyday like I don't need to
be notified I know that it exists it's
just yeah it's too much for me I
understand okay
so everyone needs to go listen to the
empty podcast it is available in the
iTunes Store search morning toast or
crazy toast tonight or if you aren't
Android user you can listen to it on
soundcloud we got into so much with him
and it was eye-opening and for someone
to the untrained eye like it is shocking
like my friends were listening she
wouldn't you know they obviously don't
read the blanks the morning toast is the
most that information they get about
celebrity gossip so like for them to
hear all of this wait I have to say
something is insane you know how you and
I are like always come in Slyke
everyone's copying us like and they are
yeah but we're also like a little
paranoid about it yes and yes we I just
want to say anyone else like any of
these other fake shows that try to be us
start talking about auntie or have NT on
like then we know because that's like
the most original idea that we have like
it's so us yeah so if that's a good way
to I've said I know like some [ __ ]
show is gonna start talking about empty
and try and get them on and that's how
we know that they're having us okay cool
I mean we're attest own everybody know
anyways check it out you will not leave
a life of one thing we didn't ask him
that I really wanted to was Ellen yeah
that's what people were saying there was
like a couple things I want to ask him
also like there were so many things that
we could have brought up if we just take
us down a rabbit hole and also we needed
to not talk about anything was important
ones like the whole pedophilia ring like
Cory Salman is doing the Lord's work out
there I'm the dozen and there's not much
more that we can do and everyone knows
what's going on sort of feels like
looking at me like but grudgingly look
what's wrong but then also we didn't ask
about the girlfriend poltergeist
okay because to be honest I've never
seen that movie because it's from the
80s and also I just don't feel like it's
relevant I know that's mean no but it's
the craziest story because she's dead no
but here are the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
okay first we need a sound effect you
know be said
a lot of yes no ever Youssef will cha
yeah we need okay oh no no no no you
don't eat like that you eat like that
yeah that's the sound of a bite in the
car do this that's how I to know or like
okay actually I can't happen
that's me the sound of egg blue chewing
gum
but don't we want people to listen to
the show we should have Olivia record it
I'm talking in Morse code
what is Morse code and is it Morris or
Morris Morse and it's like this right
like no it's like what the army uses to
send messages securely it's using legs
and such as to community yes like so one
light means something and then the
interpreter knows what they're trying to
say but then the Nazis don't so if I
were to go up to someone army and be
like this no it has nothing wouldn't
know what I'm talking about I don't know
why I thought had to be like your
eyebrows no that's like the Queen's
signals well I've been getting my
eyebrows done for $70 a day and I
thought it was because I would
eventually up to use them for Morse code
it's not a little shoulder action - okay
tell me when I'm saying what do you
check okay what am I saying um it's
really easy it's something I say all the
time grab a spoon me my ass you got it
no but that would be like but actually
it was huh now this actually means I'm
hungry but that's longer than I'm hungry
how do you know like what you just did
took longer to do than saying I'm hungry
sure okay the first story is so crazy
and for all of you who watch flipping
out which does not include us and that's
not sure I watch topping out what well
you know I love home decor shows and I
also just love like [ __ ] bosses is it
good
it is like the only thing I don't like
about it is that the turnaround time for
different projects it's like I like an
HGTV episode you see the house in the
beginning the house of the middle in the
house of the end they have like a long
project like you don't get to see the
full development it's like because it's
about his life then like the projects
okay but I just need that girl Jenny
Poulos is so incredibly annoying she
ruins the show so what do you like about
it Jeff oh okay well I mean I'm God end
over the weekend I was hanging out with
a guy and I'm not I got an avid watcher
so I didn't know but he was one of his
ex assistants his name was tres does
anyone know who that is
probably that's exciting and yeah that's
cute no now he like has his own firm
it's like super successful I think it's
like a great place to work if you're
like into that sort of thing and Lala's
gonna be on the season and Randall there
making a house oh my goodness that's so
cute
I know and he's always getting involved
in housewife drama I love him yeah
name another Dubrow for that reason yes
flipping out star Jeff Lewis is blind
sighted as daughter's surrogate Suze
Bravo over filmed birth this is so crazy
oh my god that it's crazy she didn't
give permission I'm sure she did but my
hair my bride told you this morning that
I felt like a crunchy piece piece of
bread yes you said wet when I said like
toe it's cause I got a blowout like
three dates gonna haven't watched my
hair since I'm like I drank wine last
night literally and you can feel the
spilled wine in your hairless Karen week
so you're saying that you spilled mine I
don't know but it's crunchy I just feel
so crusty like I need to take a Roman
bath you know what I mean yeah I do
oh my god I feel like those dirty girls
on Instagram who use like the gray
filter yeah okay well they look good at
least thank you flipping out stars Jeff
Lewis and gage Edward are devastated I
hate the name gage oh I thought I was
pronouncing engaged
know that you were said I think he said
they're engaged it's just it's the most
annoying names I've never heard it
before I have are devastated after news
broke that the surrogate mother of their
19 month old daughter Mont Monroe
Christine is suing Bravo claiming she
never consented that the network of
filmer delivering the baby for the show
Alexandra Trent filed a lawsuit on
Tuesday claiming that flipping out
producers filmed her vagina
without permission and that Louis and
Edward had personally humiliated her by
making the stuff's disgusting comments
on the show according to a complaint
obtained by people whose Louis and
Edward Jeff Lewis engage oh oh that's
confusing because they both have like
let her steal a sees your opinions yeah
okay here's the day I just find it so
difficult to believe like any time I've
ever been on like the backbackback
background of the reality show I've like
side my life away so I know that these P
like cross their TS and dot their eyes
so I don't believe that she never
consented also she's giving birth and
there's like six men in the room with
cameras what did she think that they
were there for also when you're
asserting you give up your body to to
the people who are paying you to do it
so like get over it well I don't know
what happened but I can imagine what
like this is what I would guess is like
she consented to being on the show
signed away all the paperwork and then
but she didn't consent having her vagina
on the show you know so she's upset
about that part and I'm sure they she
what else embarrassed by the way it's
Bravo not HBO you can't put a vagina on
Bravo no but like it was blurred out I'm
sure it was but still that's you know
not a flattering I know I just think
when you're gonna sign up to be a you
know you're in or you're out out of
you're gonna started to be a surrogate
of a couple who has a reality show you
can't now sue for overexposure why be
like Kim surrogates just cuz she's the
next story like well she is richer
richer like Jeff Lewis probably got some
brokedown
surrogate from an agency like on
Hollywood Boulevard I don't even know if
that means but people always say it
sounds like a nice treat where's Kim
like he use a high tier agency like
sorry you get what you pay for I agree I
mean I have to imagine that private god
of their eyes and credibility so I'm
sure she's just also if I learned
anything from Giuliana Rancic there's a
really big difference between a
surrogate mother and a gestational
carrier and this is a gestational
carrier like this woman is just
surrogate mother then look when when
it's the mom the woman's eggs - yeah no
it's like totally false just a tional
carrier it's like when the woman is just
being used as a home like she has no
biological connection yeah gestational
carrier and so this was a gestational
carrier yes
Oh actually I don't know whose eggs it
was so I don't know maybe it was a
surrogate perhaps okay anyways good luck
to everyone in the legal process Kim
Kardashian teaches Alice Marie Johnson
had a snapchat during first meeting
after prison pardon this story is so
cute I'm obsessed with Kim and Alice
they are squad goals totally I hope she
musta calabasas
totally Kim kardashian-west finally met
Alice Marie Johnson the 60 year 63 year
old great-grandmother she helped free
after 21 years
kardashian-west and johnson celebrated
the moment in memphis on snapchat
Wednesday two weeks after President
Donald Trump pardoned Johnson following
Kardashian West's months long campaign
Johnson was sent to prison in 1996 so
she was not familiar with the photo
sharing app but now we're probably Kim
yeah but not to worry Kardashian
instructed her on the use of the many
filters on snapchat which was founded in
September 2011 Alice has never used
filters before so I'm showing her the
ropes love you Alice the wife of Kanye
West said in one of the videos also on
Wednesday the pair sat down with Hoda
copy for Today Show interview every
Thursday yeah quote I love this woman
the Keeping Up with the Kardashians
reality star said after sharing a hug
with Johnson who responded I love this
lady
they're so cute no like seriously to be
able to talk about this on the show
I'm the podcast in Nashville we talked
about it briefly I believe because I
just can't believe like how mean
everyone was to Kim and look at the end
of the day all she was trying to do was
a really nice thing and she succeeded
she succeeded and the fact that like
people still aren't giving her credit
and like making fun of her like it's
really making me upset I feel like
people are done making fun of her but
like shame on everyone who did make fun
of her because what she's did is such a
nice thing and she's unbelievable she
said I mean I already knew you just by
talking to on the phone and just seeing
you in videos but I mean you are
everything and more than I ever thought
no it's just like all these celebrities
and influencers like do good charity
charity work yeah but like you've never
seen like direct results whereas I Kim
literally like decided she wanted to do
this and she did it and I just like
honestly I'm so proud of her
yeah I'm so proud of her it's it's
really it's huge I want to watch their
interview where she's wearing I could
meet you like she's so serious of course
I mean that outfit she wore to the White
House was absolutely horrible but she
did what she had to do but like what
else is she she wouldn't she wouldn't
have gotten her a pardoned if she were
at war some thought he dress yeah if she
wore like easy season six honestly that
would be down though have you been seen
then I was just gonna ask if you if you
saw those titty shots I do I never liked
what's real and what's just like going
viral you know and like maybe I just
don't understand fashion but like what's
with all the dirty spandex but like
holes in it I don't know but then I was
thinking like it's crazy
when Kim wear something like she it's
she's always the first so it's like a
little weird but then like in a year you
see everyone wearing it no now like
people wearing oversized puffers and
like biker shorts that are white like
totally fine yeah
wearing like those chunky sneakers
horrible and like a really long hair and
like whatever happened to just like
pretty clothes that are just like
universally pretty you didn't mean like
why do you have to wear like weird [ __ ]
no but like I get it it's fashion but
it's just so crazy though yes senex okay
it's it's all there to your taste it's
special gonna be attending Mellencamp
I mean ASOS is fashion so it totally is
don't be a Teddy Mellencamp I couldn't
agree more
right like I let everyone express
themselves in the way they see fit
okay ready for this next story and the
way that someone is spread express
himself in the way that was not fit oh
my god I know exactly so crazy
it's disgusting Jamie Foxx has been
accused in 2002 of slapping someone with
his penis he denies it and will fight
back legally reports TMZ Jamie Foxx is
being accused of slapping a woman with
his penis nearly 16 years ago and
although she's now gone to police Fox
says it's an absurd lie and he's going
after her legally TMZ has learned the
alleged assault happened in Las Vegas
back in 2002 according to law
enforcement the accuser told cops last
week she and a friend were attending a
party at Jamie's place when he tried to
get her to perform oral sex
she claims when she refused Jamie struck
her in the face with his penis
the accuser tells us after the alleged
assault one of Jamie's friends told her
she had to go get out of the house she
claims she went to the hospital the next
day
when she got back to home in LA to get
treatment for a severe panic attack
lorne law enforcement's tell us Vegas PD
lists the case as an open investigation
however the statute of limitations has
long run long since Ron it's the statute
of limitation is three years in Nevada
it's very short okay here's the thing
innocent until proven guilty so either
Jamie did this and he came up with the
idea to slap a woman with his dick or
this woman came up with the idea like
whoever whoever's idea it was like who
is creative as [ __ ] like that is a wild
wild thing to do to like literally
instead of using like a baton just like
use your dick yes but only a true
sociopath can think of something like
that yeah I'm yeah like that's so crazy
like with Angie saying yesterday that
like Harvey Weinstein like ejaculated
into a potted plant like true creativity
at its finest yeah no but like just or
just like troub or like he kept saying
how like stars get to this level of like
Preta deixa sness because of Giselle and
then they've been doing it for so long
so like then stuff like this happens and
it's just another day in the life and
empty saying that TMZ isn't owned by
Warner Brothers is like the most
shocking thing ever the most ever
because I always wondered like when
something is not reported like why not
and especially TMZ because I feel like
they're the slew theus there's a sue
theist like they have they really go out
of their way to bring us the facts
straight from the courthouse but the
little dogs but then they don't
someone's always protecting someone else
it's so crazy in the show SATA and
speaking of um auntie alluded to this
yesterday the Ke$ha Katy Perry Lady Gaga
saga lady saga the Lady Gaga saga the
lady
kisara dr. Luke denied Kesha has claimed
that he briefed Katy Perry because of
course he did um but I'm just so sick
I'm so sick of Doc I'm hearing about dr.
Luke no no I'm so sick of hearing about
dr. Luke and not and not in a gel cap I
don't know but not even that like as
he's still like working as a music
producer and making money like up the
wazoo money I literally never see in my
whole life yeah like it's honest to god
Bo [ __ ] I'm so done with the corruption
and the hypocrisy and the misogyny and
the did I say corruption corruption
that's what this is at its core
corruption and more than that mood today
I just still can't get out of her
contract like I said though like my
kidney just let her go you know in the
words of my dear friend Elsa
let it go that
I'm still taking vocal lessons reality
for that purpose um after yesterday's
interview you really want to get into
the music industry no I want to get into
the music industry whatsoever but I just
think your voice is a muscle and it's
important that you flex it every now and
then okay if anyone was a vocal coach
well there's the thing I took vocal
classes in NYU and I was like holy
disappointing it's like I just wanted to
come in there and be like don't tell me
not to live just sittin pot and like you
need to join a glee club I'm sure
there's a goloka local adult glee club
because ready night school glee all I
wanted to do was like sing Mariah Carey
first I had to do this and then when it
came time to sing
I didn't think classical [ __ ] like
this waking bird she sings songs of
fairy butterflies of flowers and kindly
things but when she sings that seems to
me no car on earth could lovely happy
when sweet actually quite pleasing but I
thought you were gonna say our favorite
classical town from the award-winning
film raise your voice detail
it's okay to look fat obviously people
who don't get that reference I don't
have time I can truly connect with you
like that is the most important
reference of our generation and if you
don't know what I'm talking about like
buy buy a ticket pack your bags go to
hell
and if you don't know but you want to
know watch raise your voice and which is
also like such a good movie such a good
movie I want to watch it I have some
things to watch I need to go into the
vault I have some things to watch this
weekend yeah me too oh my god cuz you
know how excited I am for this weekend
there hasn't been a weekend probably in
a year that I haven't like gone out or
been away this weekend is my weekend to
shine I got a gross I never had food in
my house which is shocking because I'm
fat as hell but like any time I just
want to eat a quarter McDonald's but he
never have like snacks or like meals or
like pasta I mean I never have anything
so Jackie told me about this app called
Peapod where they literally deliver
groceries to you and usually that [ __ ]
is expensive because I did it once but
this one is very usable it's stop and
shop which is a very recently priced
grocery store
I ordered legit groceries for a month
one hundred dollars including delivery
they came early today I got I came so I
did the same time pick up as you they
came so mine came at 7:30 well I mine
came at like 8:05 so they probably went
to him and they came back at 8:15 was I
didn't answer the door okay so literally
I got so that this weekend is gonna be
the weekend of staying in and making
food my fresh food even fresh fruit I
got grilled chicken I'm so excited for
you I think this is gonna be baby pasta
I
I got Rayo sauce my favorite I got so
many chips like literally I had to put
them on the stove because I didn't have
anywhere else to put them like this man
cabinet was all microwave popcorn rice
cakes yeah I got so my god Italian ice
chip which is punch tickles like
literally I feel like a suburban mom
with my groceries like it's amazing I am
putting your order in every week cut and
I'm sure I think you put in of course
for us good I cook Snapple water oh my
god my dad my whole fringe is beverages
and then you've ever done a [ __ ]
three to two dollars for the for Amazon
this place everything you know what I
love doing recently because like
obviously we hate drinking water I can
only drink so much seltzer before like I
get hard water
die coke isn't good for you I've been
high
a cold glass of iced tea but like
Crystal Light what kind of ice - um like
Arizona iced tea diet it's so tasty
I'm just really it's just such a treat
no one's thank you no take any tag
ticket to do an interview
take II feel like he'd never seen him
before so what Co the last time we saw
you is your it was your one-year
birthday why didn't you do that hate to
celebrate I heard you got crazy I read
some blinds about you and they were I
[ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] and I just on
the drugs it was super faded bro
Wow Co one years old though don't you
think you should slow down you only live
once bro am i right socio you are a
degenerate did you learn that from your
parents not [ __ ] I learned it from you
Wow Thanks yeah you make me sound so
cool they're cool and Sneetches huh oh
my gosh I like you miss your other hand
see just now that [ __ ] left us we don't
need her oh are you gonna visit her [ __ ]
that
getting on a plane are you kidding my
people on a plane planes I would
literally never eat dinner white because
you know guys I don't know if you've
heard but I'm kicking off from Asia tour
this summer it's legit a tour I need to
come up with a name for my tour even
those like not a legit tour it's like
nobody's Victoria what's we call it like
what am i what am i what are the focal
points so one of my comedic heroes is um
Jim Gaffigan and I modeled my website
like legit after his and the name of his
uh-oh the name of his tour is hilarious
what is it the noble ape like he's
hilarious
and what would mine be like the chubby
Jew I don't know no like what are the
names of tours like what's dead means
about other tell me you love me tour
okay that's like a song yeah or like the
reputation tour right okay so what's
like my what's the song that I sang the
I'm not a girl not yet a woman tour wait
that's a great idea but just too long
it's kind of long the CEOs mom tour okay
sweet back to my original point maybe
some toasters will come up with some
good idea but I really want to take deal
with me like I'm gonna be alone a lot
and like I just think it'll be really
good to have him but I can't I'm
literally so afraid to take him I'm
playing if you took him in your
seat under the seat he'd be fine that
the dog has yet to go that way unless
they tell you they put him in the
overhead bin oh my god I'd get off a
plane in which case you get off and then
you'll got so many miles that I mean so
many Instagram followers I would
literally in stock though I mean
document the whole thing yeah I think
the chickie would be okay I just feel
like he's too rambunctious for the place
he is I'm going to be running down the
aisles like everyone would love him
totally he really is a service animal he
brings great joy to people commit joy
he's so he's my everything look what are
we to before him what the hell did we
talk about I don't know I don't know he
really wants to get down but I'm not
letting him know he he abused his time
down um so if anyone has any good
suggestions for my comedy show also
tickets available at Clara girl with a
tour the Justice tour oh not bad no like
maybe something about life I make with
no job terrible sorry these are all
terrible ones night stand terrible
terrible um you guys I'm wildly
discipline girl with a Comedy Tour
terrible clods come each have again the
journey genes to our that's good that's
great Sarah Posey done the dirty jeans I
don't work and I don't want to pay
anyone so someone make artwork for me of
like a beautiful photo of myself and it
says literally jeans tour that's such a
good name yeah grab a oh he likes it
that's why oh ok Theo part lapel because
he likes the name of his mom's tour the
dirty jeans tour you say like that
five nights in a row haha that's so good
oh my god you should make I'd have to
say like this he's like nah dread the
dirty jeans tour five nights in a row
I'm gonna love it I think I've to wear
dirty jeans now well I do anyway no
jamas the dirty PJs tour okay no I
should just have like my a pair of my
dirty jeans like hanging above me oh my
god that's actually very creative
and oh my god with like a legit like I
hearing that on
that's so funny oh my god I'm crying
okay what's bad okay the next door is a
two-parter for all our One Tree Hill
fans out there cuz there's been a lot of
of [ __ ] that's come out two stories
first of all Chad Michael Murray fires
back a tech Sophia Bush has claimed that
she felt pressured to marry him I always
forget that they were married and I
don't didn't watch One Tree Hill me
neither
and I feel like the person she was when
she was felling let your Hill is like
not who she is at all word to these days
no I know and like I think it's hard for
the fans to reconcile but luckily I'm
not a fan yeah
even though I do plan on watching it
meet not only at one point I planned on
watching it but I no longer do just
because I also I feel like the shows are
only good when you're like a dumb
moronic kid like I'm an adult now I see
through all this [ __ ] I know I feel
like I feel like Gossip Girl is still
good because it's like definitely like
elevated and Friday Night Lights was
good when I we watch it last year but I
just feel like One Tree Hill is like
there's a reason we didn't watch it in
2008 no totally but really we should
have watched it mm like we didn't and
you know I so busy we were so busy with
the OC like we couldn't but like we
needed something to fill the OCS gap and
like we should have turned to one tree
hill but we didn't and you know what I'm
gonna trust my 15 year old South has to
ride and watch it back but Chad Michael
Murray can completely get it like in my
eyes I said I don't really know what he
looks like these days but him and Freaky
Friday pretend a Cinderella story like I
was very much here for it yeah see well
she didn't interview with Andy for his
radio Andy show and she touched on her
brief marriage to the actor saying quote
it was not a thing I actually really
wanted to do adding she felt pressure to
marry him and then a statement to people
Chad Michael Murray's rep said that the
story is ludicrous Chad conducts himself
in a completely professional manner and
would never marry for any reason but
love 13 years since his divorce from
Sophia he has a very happy life with his
wife and children I feel like honestly
that's such a mean thing to say like to
completely discredit your marriage like
whatever the reasons are that you
divorce great whatever but like don't
let me take away from like the Matt like
I don't want you think that's Mary -
that was five months like really yeah
um I took it back yeah I need to stop
saying things like no but like it
statements over here I get where you're
like ain't just one fell swoop it's like
it it discredits like a whole love
affair right but now I'm learning it was
no such level no but it wasn't maybe not
a great love affair but I was no
Cinderella story it was no Cinderella
story you know I get confused between
like just when they were kids I know
very much that they're different now but
like Chad Michael Murray and chat
Channing Tatum yeah I was little you
know because like the way that he the
way that Channing Tatum looks and she's
the man is don't worry they they both
like we're like would go up for the same
parts for sure and their names start
with the same three letters
yeah chatting and Chad no it's just like
more thing named Channing is yeah but
like why can't he also just be Chad
Marie totally like like Vanessa and
hundreds new to drop the you know she
still and she'll always be an to me no
to you but but she's rebranded so what's
the second part of the story the second
part of the story in the same interview
she says she talks about so mark Schwahn
is the creator and he's like a rampant
assaulter oh yeah so and a lot of
assaulting was going down on the set of
One Tree Hill in a new interview on
Sirius XM's Andy Cohen live Bush
recalled at least one instance in which
she herself was inappropriately touched
by chuan oh dear well the first time
right the first time mark Schwahn
grabbed my ass I hit him in front of six
other producers she said and I hit him
[ __ ] hard but she then went on to
reveal that Chauhan grew quote super
obsessed with at least one other one
tree hill actress saying he started
trying to bang down her hotel room door
in the middle of the night she had to be
moved and then her boyfriend came and
stayed with her for the next month it
almost came to fisticuffs between the
two of them oh my god I'm absolutely
sure crazier than this is three days
after the One Tree Hill letter was
released where they all came out against
mark Schwahn the women of the Royals
which is also produced by him had
similar claims is he still working um no
he was fired by me but the fact that
like he was working up until now a few
months ago knows and like they're not
gonna stop working with these people
until a letter is written like morons
will fit until the public knows but but
just because if they stopped working
with everyone who's an assaulter there
would be no one left working
you could hire new people hi I've truly
never salted anyone in my life except
for my dog could hire unproblematic
women and then there are such things
there are such things so justice for
everyone on the set of One Tree Hill
like that sounds like a [ __ ]
nightmare also I just saw on your iPad
there's an advertisement for a show
called strange angel and I'm just
absolutely in shock that they didn't
think to call it the strange ol Claudia
there is a commercial for cascade no
dish issues to shoot Claudia it's more
frustrating then what is it because it's
a case of theft sonic the burger plays
huh
with Jackie white and can I say that
yeah and it's she talks it out like the
item is called something something where
you can complete it she's like and she
does it she's like I just love putting
two words together like it's a dish
issues dishes situation well but I
forget what the words are okay so what's
a problem that they that's what we do
okay I don't I don't claim intellectual
property over that like that's a
generational thing oh I don't know
someone I don't know no it's not who
else doesn't know that's a problem no no
people do it yeah I don't claim that's
ours
I wish more people did it no say but I
don't claim that it's ours you're very
forgiving well me not so much
I'm no I go through stages where I'm
like truly paranoid and like I watch
everyone else's like podcasts web series
radio shows and I'm like oh my god
that's totally song for me but then
sometimes I'm like you just gotta let go
and let God sometimes you know I'm
saying sure yeah no I'm saying bro yeah
okay next up really sad news nene leakes
husband Gregg Leakes was diagnosed with
cancer what I do hear about this yeah
nene leakes announced on Wednesday that
her husband Gregg Leakes is battling
cancer quote our new normal and the
fight begins The Real Housewives of
Atlanta star 50 revealed on Instagram
with a picture of Gregg sitting with his
arms crossed and the word cancer crossed
out behind him that's so sad
Gregg's health has been up and down for
the last several months in May Gregg who
has married and divorced and remarried
Nene spent a total of 16 days in the
hospital
I like regardless of how you feel about
like the Atlanta like the drama between
the housewives I loved Gregg Leakes I
think he's like a stand-up guy I love
that they got back together there yeah
oh cute and they got remarried like I
just think it's so great that is so sad
and I hope honestly I really hope Kim
Biermann reaches out cuz like she went
through some health issues also
think this is the time this could be the
thing that brings him back together much
like last night on Real Housewives in
New York Bobby's Erin's funeral wait I
didn't see because I had like a
four-hour meeting because I'm in a while
tomorrow yes and it was a really sad sad
episode Mike was that little episode the
funeral for no it was there was also
like the dumb drama and like stupid [ __ ]
they went to like a con body class it's
like a workout class modeled after a
prison to like make fun of LuAnn like it
was so stupid that means yeah I really
didn't like it um but they played like a
lot of the old footage that they had of
Jill and Bobby like of their photos and
like try not to cry oh really yeah and
like Bethenny and Jill like are we're on
the men's like she went to the funeral
and like it was it was just really sad
I'm so sad I really don't want but I
think Bethenny and Jill are friends
again
and apparently like Bobby always wanted
them to become friends again oh yeah
like what in and so it's like his last
gift was like bringing that throat
together when when they broke up Jill
and Bethenny whose team are you on oh I
at first like everyone else I was on
Jill side because what like Jill gave
her this platform and it seemed like
this but when Beth when Jill did not
forgive Bethenny then I was on Bethenny
side completely because she when they
were in that apartment in Ramona's
apartment its Luann's fault why they
never and I think that's why Bethenny
always has an out for who and whose
lands fault why he never got back
together when they're sitting there and
Bethenny is crying and and she's like
just trying to like start fresh which is
what friends do especially best friends
and Jill never forgave her then it was
then I was team Bethenny forever until
then Bethenny like God ahead of herself
and right so I was actually like a Jill
I was on Jill side the whole time
regardless I don't think she was a
hundred percent right but like you know
you got to stand someone and the network
totally took Bethenny side and then like
Bethenny blew up she had Bethenny
getting married Bethenny Ever After
Bethenny talk show and I was like pissed
and now I wish all of that was happening
for her now because I found her so
insufferable back in the day but now I
love her but I feel like she had to go
through on that be a little humbled
because you like truly you don't only go
up and then like still have your head
attached to your body like it's it's
pretty near impossible so I think having
like a few failures but also a lot of
success has made her the person that she
is now that we do like yes no I love her
now
and I never thought I would because I
found her so [ __ ] annoying oh so
speaking of annoying like you know I
love Tinsley and it's very hard for her
to do so I had this conversation with
someone last night she's getting on my
nerves
she did something last night that was so
terrible finally please know you I mean
it does it's not like anything crazy
she went try she's still dating Scott
and she went trying on wedding dresses
with her mom and it was like the moat
like the most worse omen thing you could
do like I was having anxiety for her
it's like nothing good comes of this
count up the chickens before they act
counting your frozen embryos before they
hatch she's sitting in her wedding dress
facetiming her doctor looking at photos
of her embryos crying it's the craziest
thing like it was it was so like not
durable it was and like her mom was
crying too but neither of their faces
moved it was like so strange it was said
okay I'll watch when I get home and you
know that I love her no I know but she's
getting really annoying and honestly
like her and Carol I'm not here for the
Alliance I agree it's not good only bad
good things can you know what they need
to do in order to like have a chef this
reunions gonna be explosive I've just
writing in their blogs like ours just
that control all the belts I will never
forget some of the things Carol said
about Bethenny in the blog that is I
think the meanest thing I've ever read I
totally agree it's below the belt and
the reunions gonna be fire but then for
next season what I would like to see
like if I were in charge I would bring
on one of Tim sleaze friends because
it's the easiest way to cause a rift
between Tinsley and Carol and honestly
so funny I mean and see how real that
friendship I was watching st. Barths
Tomas episodes yesterday and Carol was
so great back then she wasn't a super
main character between the best
commentary she had the best she had the
most side
moments she was like whatever Sonja did
with Tomas is illegal in 48 states like
she was just like funny and like witty
and like now she's nothing like that
she's like condescending and like
negative I totally agree you know who
she's reminding me of who Carrie
Bradshaw like she's like she's writing
for Cosmo she hasn't started and she's
just like being so negative and like
acting like a child when she's not
amazing call thank you I just want to
remind everyone that the dirty jeans
tour is kicking off June 28th in Chicago
I'm coming to Chicago I'm coming to
Denver I'm coming to st. Louis I'm
coming to Palm Beach I'm going to
Phoenix I'm going come beat your West
Palm
actually it's West Palm that's where I
had to put in the the address for the
venue and it said West mom oh my god so
yes hybrid um where else am I going Jax
Phoenix palm desert filly
hostal Alabama Boston's coming and I'm
still Alabama that's the ones how I'm
gonna make it better at a point to go
down yeah and is it like a college near
there when is Huntsville's show enough
for a while okay good except my
traveling for a while I know I'm like
I'm really excited to kick off a story
it's gonna be unbelievably epic but like
I need to like start getting into like
drugs so I don't have to be alive on
planes I can not stand plane it's like
seriously it's unbearable I mean or you
could get a big bus and they can bring
this Higgs so actually that'd be awesome
but if we better interesante and getting
tickets girl no job calm claudia calm or
just my Instagram stories oh and I had
one more thing to say about tensley
because what she did for Sonya at the
hotel is the nicest thing I've ever seen
a friend do let her sister wouldn't you
let her say there she instead of
sleeping in her bed she got her the
penthouse suite with all of these gifts
a Louie Vuitton never full bag like all
of these things like finally make up for
what she did but it was like Antonia's
displaced because her house is under
renovation until like imagine you think
you're just gonna crash with your friend
and like you got the nicest feet was so
not grateful yes they have and she got
her like a such a pretty robe and they
were just like having a great time okay
I'm actually excited to watch episode
that was for last
oh but we were jumping oh yes it sounds
like a roller coaster of emotions a
Ramona coaster to be exact if you
haven't caught up on our NT special
edition episode from yesterday I highly
suggest it it's gonna meet one of our
most about two episodes it's only been
20 it's been less than 24 hours and it's
already it's really up there so and the
part of the feedback isn't saying like
my Twitter is not stop blowing up since
the second we put the we bethabeth Gondo
tweets about in John Jodi I mean he's
like thank you for mentioning my Twitter
so then I really thought the John toad
Twitter was written run by NT and I
thought he lied to us yesterday but then
when the person DM to me it's a hundred
percent of girl oh really
it was just like the girliest message
ever oh that's so for gay man um
the John Doe Twitter is great because
it's like just someone who has fans of
NT like us but then it's also like
blinds 101 where it does the blind with
the accompanying headline and it's a
great place for starter blinders so it's
gonna be
it's it's superlight so i really suggest
you watch it we're back tomorrow if
you're a new toaster you want to
convince one of your friends to be
toaster the morning toast is basically
Milan mmm I have the hardest time saying
this it's okay it's basically a
millennial Morning Show we talk about
all the things you truly care about
housewives Beverly Hills all that stuff
she's she's she's she's she darling
so we go live on Facebook and YouTube
every morning 10:30 a.m. Eastern time so
make sure you like us on Facebook make
sure you're subscribe to us on YouTube
and then if you're commuter and you like
those commuter babes we're also
available as a podcast so make sure you
subscribe to the morning shows and the
podcast app leave a five star review
about how gorgeous talented and amazing
we are I'm your loyal host Claudia a
girl with no job
tickets to the dirty dirty jeans tour I
can't believe that like I have a thing
to say it out it's so good
ticket to the dirty jeans to our belt
recom that's so funny
I'm your host Jackie ashtray at Jackie O
problems have a great day